whoever said that rules were made to be
broken never danced under Abby Lee
Miller's watchful eye here are ten of
the most unbelievable rules the cast of
Dance Moms was made to follow catch on
quick or else it's no secret that
growing up on the set of Dance Moms can
be super stressful Nia Maddie Mackenzie
and Chloe have all posted YouTube videos
explaining just how active their lives
used to be not the studio every second
despite Dance Moms being a reality TV
show there were many instances where the
girls were instructed to fake it till
they make it during a tell-all vlog Nia
revealed that a not-so-secret Dance Moms
rule went along the lines of catch on
quick or get out of the studio the girls
had a very limited amount of time to
learn their dance routines
despite the show making it seem like
they had an entire week to do this in
reality they usually had anywhere
between a few hours to a few days tops
but they were expected to catch on quick
or face the consequences no makeup no
dancing it's totally normal for parents
to want to stop their young girls from
wearing makeup before they reach a
suitable age but if you're planning on
becoming a dance mom you'll have to
reconsider your morals Abby Lee wants
all the girls to have a fresh face of
makeup whenever the cameras are around
no matter how young they are she wants
everyone to look their best and that's a
rule you can't ignore failing to wear
makeup while being filmed will set
Abby's nerves sky-high and you don't
want to mess with Abby when she's angry
the pyramid rule every day is Mamas fan
knows a thing or two about pyramid day
and they also know that there's no
escaping it
being present on pyramid day was a must
and it forced the girls to be
scrutinized while one dancers abilities
were praised Maddie failed to attend the
dreadful weekly events could result in a
contract breach which simply wasn't an
option to make matters worse the girls
were made to stand straight throughout
the entire ordeal which was super
uncomfortable
actually it's for standing up straight
for a few hours while being criticized
is something we never want to do still
the last rule on this list makes the
pyramid rule sound like a breeze dance
mom rules
the dancers weren't the only ones being
watched though because their mothers
also had a little rulebook to follow if
they signed to the Dance Moms contract
they were basically agreeing to forego
their careers and become a full-time
dance mom on top of that the mothers had
to respect Abby's studio time they could
watch from afar but they weren't
supposed to enter the studio when Abby
was teaching but of course not every
single dance mom was going to respect
this rule especially when they could see
Abby yelling at their kids for no
apparent reason but if there's one rule
every dance mom learned relatively
quickly it was to never question Abby
Lee Miller because well they would live
to regret it no school on Fridays to say
that the girls had a wildly hectic
schedule would be an understatement we
have two trios and a group dance dancing
came first and school came second which
wasn't exactly ideal many of the girls
had to stop attending public school and
resort to being tutored across the
street from Abby Lee's dance studio but
not all of them wanted to sever ties
with their schools and friends so many
of them juggled public school and
professional dancing at the same time
but there was a catch the girls weren't
allowed to go to school on Fridays
because well Fridays were left open for
competitions their rituals
believe it or not but the dancers had a
self-inflicted rule that could not be
ignored while it wasn't exactly appease
doing the girls became incredibly
superstitious during their time on Dance
Moms
according to Nia if the girls didn't do
their special handshake before
performing the number they would totally
butcher their performance they also
believed in jinxes which led them to
knock on wood and perform small rituals
whenever they attempted their faith
these rules were taken very seriously
despite not being an Abby Lee Miller's
contract no piercings no tattoos every
dance studio has its own set of rules an
Abby Lee Miller is no exception not
being allowed to have facial piercings
sounds pretty reasonable
after all judges do look at a dancers
overall image when giving a verdict
however Abby Lee was a lot stricter than
the average person
according to Chloe wearing piercings of
any kind was absolutely forbidden and so
was getting tattoos while these rules
didn't impact the girls during their
junior years it's safe to say that
became annoying once they were teenagers
according
to a be wearing jewelry can be dangerous
but still what's the harm in wearing
studded earrings prim and proper Abby
Lee Miller wants her dancers to be prim
and proper at all times she wants them
to be completely natural with the
exception of makeup of course her
dancers are required to have their hair
up in the studio and failing to do so
can get them kicked out in a jiffy
just ask Chloe perhaps the most
important role the girls have to follow
is keeping their hair completely natural
dyeing your hair getting highlights or
putting some funky colors in it is
forbidden yet somehow Jojo was still
allowed on the show did you guys know
that JoJo's mom has been bleaching her
daughter's hair since she was a kid
it looks like Abby chose to let that one
slide no tears no complaining it's old
news that Abby Lee Miller has little to
no patience and an extreme hatred for
crybabies according to her being yelled
at and ridiculed isn't a good enough
reason for children to cry all in all
Abby is super ruthless and hates
complainers Abby has a bunch of rules
listed on the ALDC official page and one
of them states that dancers should come
to class with ambition energy and a
positive attitude we don't know about
you but that seems like a lot to ask
three-year-olds and emotional preteens
though wait role it's totally normal for
dance studios to have some pretty
atrocious rules but the weight rule
simply takes the cake Chloe was one of
the few girls to refuse to sign Abby's
contract due to how ridiculous it was it
said that the girls weren't allowed to
gain or lose 5 to 10 pounds and had to
sign away 10% of their earnings Chloe
refused to do this and wasn't allowed on
the show for the beginning of season 4
can you imagine telling your little girl
to monitor her weight if she intends to
continue dancing at ALDC yeah we didn't
think so
so which dance moms rule did you find
the most ridiculous let us know in the
comment section below thanks for
watching the things for more videos like
this one hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time
[Music]